the most important thing for
cosmologists is precision cosmology when
I started graduate school in the mid 90s
we didn't know if the universe was 10
billion years old or 20 billion years
old now we know it's 13.824 billion
years old and we have a Precision of
less than one percent and we also have
an accuracy in other words we have
calibrated that number and removed
systemic contamination from that number
it's really phenomenal I mean at that
time we knew of objects that were older
than the universe supposedly there were
objects called globular clusters and
they were older than the universe that's
like finding out that you're older than
your mother I mean it's very bizarre
situation and quite frankly it was
embarrassing to cosmologists now we know
with extreme Precision with that
Precision comes great power and that
power allows us to assess what is the
nature of this dark energy potentially
and not only that what is it doing to
our future understanding of where the
universe will continue to develop in the
Far Far distant future and so if the
universe truly has this dark energy
chimeric form of energy G unknown
completely you know unlike anything
we've ever had an experience with that
type of energy will eventually Drive the
universe potentially in a variety of
different ways none of them good but
luckily they don't come about for tens
to perhaps hundreds of billions of years
when the universe might physically rip
apart there could be aspects of
space-time that at all locations develop
what we call singularities the breakdown
in all the laws of physics and certainly
long before then we will have stopped
having the ability to do astronomy or
cosmology we will no longer be able to
see any other galaxies after a certain
point after the universe has expanded so
much those galaxies will all be
redshifted so far out of observational
constraints that we won't even know we
live in a galaxy we'll just think this
is the entire universe so ironically
we'll be back to the way the State of
Affairs was in pre-1929 planet Earth's
understanding of cosmology with the
Precision that I mentioned before that
we know the age of the universe we know
the expansion rate of the universe first
we can do astounding things I remember
when my children turned two years old
you take them to the pediatrician's
office and they measure their height and
basically they've got this rule of thumb
based on the statistics of 100 billion
people that have lived on planet Earth
to date that the child will be about
twice as high twice as tall as he or she
is at age two so imagine if you went and
you go to the pediatrician and then you
come back in 10 years 15 years 20 years
and the kid is like 30 times bigger than
that height or or one tenth is tall well
you'd say this is crazy there's
something strange going on your tables
are all messed up and your actual
statistical sample is not a good
representation of the parent population
no pun intended so the question becomes
how accurately Can you estimate how fast
the universe will be expanding today
versus 13 billion years ago and there's
what's called attention because the two
numbers disagree and they disagree by a
violently inacceptable amount the
measurements that we do with the cosmic
microwave background radiation suggest a
universe that is billion years younger
if you like then the universe that we
see using the type 1A supernovae and
that tension is a lot a billion years is
a big difference that's a current
problem we don't know the Hubble
constant's value it disagrees at what's
called five standard deviations so
there's a one part and several million
that it could be a statistical fluke and
they're both actually the same or it
could be that the physics of the early
universe that I study is very different
than the physics of the late time
universe that my colleagues who study
supernovae study
foreign